I haven't been able to sleep since then, and
I'm worried that the doorbell will ring any minute, so
Oseko is fussy.  Also,
there is a fan of Nikaido who won 1 billion yen in the lottery.
voodoo ok That's fine
Really go to the road pound Book, me and Nikaido
Such a future map Blow kiss is also a canoe pou dou dou
wnn A lot of cows are data love and painted version
I'm
the strongest person in history
.
But he's a
good duck If it's 10 million Nissenman,
I'll bet the 5th ward separately and get gravity.
I've already set the game for today, what will I do after that?
The gravity of the lottery is all about confining oh my until you cash it in.
Kakihana, as long as you have physical strength, it might be the last
time.
When I heard about it, I thought
Kodai was fine
.